the newest rogue one trailer included
some moments that provoked major nerding
out from the Star Wars fans here in the
gamespot office here are four
potentially spoilery theories that we
came up with Jed ha the mecca of Jedi
religion definitely gets blown up
there's a line the last trailer about a
new weapons tests being imminent and we
think that Jedi is the target of that
test three of the rogue one crew called
Jed ha home so that may be a major
motivator to kick some Imperial ass we
think the whole rebel fleet is going to
get some action the presence of Nebulon
be escort frigates Mon Calamari cruisers
and Corellian Corvettes behind these
x-wings is a good indication that the
whole team came out to support this
battle probably takes place in the
orbital shipyards around the planet
Scariff where the Death Star was created
just like in Return of the Jedi we think
we're gonna see a battle happening
concurrently in space and on land one on
the surface of Scariff featuring a cargo
version of the 8080 walkers and one in
space with the previously mentioned
rebel fleet ok it's gonna get really
theoretical in here for a second I think
director Orson krenek is going to redeem
himself at the end because Darth Vader
looks so pissed off in this scene based
on an early synopsis from a book coming
out in November krenek was an old friend
of Galen Ursa the lead character Jin's
father maybe Vader is angry because
krenek decides to betray the Empire in
the end to save his friend's daughter or
maybe he just messes up and gets forced
choked we noted out really hard on a two
minute trailer so when the movie comes
out we might explode for more on your
favorite comic books TV shows and movies
check out gamespot universe